Who are you? Anyway you did the right thing taking
the serum of course i know about that i actually
think it is the second best choice you've ever
made in your life i'll tell you something. It has made you
very very valuable to certain people welcome back
everyone this is going to be my new falcon and winter
soldier episode 6 finale predictions video there's
a whole bunch of storylines they have to pay off
and a whole bunch of stuff that they're setting
up for future marvel movies and other disney plus
series so we'll break it all down if you're brand
new to the channel i'm doing videos for all the
marvel disney plus series this year loki episodes
are coming next so be sure to subscribe to get
all the episodes and we'll do a new disney plus
giveaway too for memberships all you have to do
to enter is just be a subscriber and post all your
predictions for the finale on the video obviously
careful for spoilers for all the episodes that
have happened so far if you haven't seen them
yet but just starting with number 10 falcon will
probably wind up showing up to new york city to
stop the flag smashers and john walker even
though he doesn't realize that john walker is
going to be there in his new vibranium looking
captain america wingsuit it'll probably have a
whole bunch of upgrades over the last wingsuit as
implied it's wakanda tech it's built by wakanda
the last suit was not built by them it is sort of
this treasure trove of storytelling for all these
hidden abilities because they haven't completely
explained vibranium technology it's so advanced
that it's almost like magic like the way that iron
man transitioned to the nano tech versions of his
armor in avengers infinity war and avengers end
game they could literally do anything that you
wanted them to do on a story level so that's why
there were so many surprises and big wtf reveals
during that battle in avengers end game so it's
the same thing with falcon's new captain america
looking wingsuit and obviously it probably looks
something very close to the version that we saw
in the comics he'll probably also get some sort
of replacement for the red wing drone obviously
redwing in the comics is an actual physical
character a biological character that works
with him but in the movies they turned it into
a drone that he uses carly and the flag smashers
destroyed the last red wing press f in the chat to
pay respects so hopefully there'll be some sort of
replacement for that also you have the idea that
torres is supposed to become the next version
of falcon in the comics after falcon becomes the
next captain america so they might also pull off
that transition in some sort of ending scene just
implying that he will eventually fix falcon's old
wings and use them himself number nine john walker
is probably going to get that phone call from val
as she teased pick up the phone when i call you
madame hydra whatever you want to call her i don't
think they're ever going to call her madame
hydra during the disney plus series but she's
probably going to tell him to go to new york city
to get rid of the flag smasher so the grc vote can
move all the refugees into different camps and go
forward just to explain what's going on with that
it's basically a massive deportation like if a
few european countries where most of what they're
talking about most of the events of the series are
taking place even though it's implied that the grc
is acting all over the world most of this on the
series has been localized to a couple european
countries it'd be like them basically deporting
their entire homeless population like you know
what we don't want you here so we're just going
to move you into a couple of giant concentration
camps and because we're talking about the captain
america movies being inspired by all those
the world war ii concentration camp metaphor is
supposed to be pretty obvious here even though
in present day the grc was born out of avengers
end game and the blip where everyone came back
and the reason for doing this the reason why the
grc is doing this is basically what amounts to
all the blip people including criminals like
evil people that got blipped back and all the
other characters on the spectrum of good and evil
basically saying give me back all my stuff to the
people who did not get snapped and sort of moved
into other territories i used the spider-man in
aunt may example from spider-man far from home
a couple videos ago aunt may joked that she got
blit back but in her apartment another family
had already moved in in that five year time span
so during the events of that movie they used it
for more of a comedic spin like oh my god she's
a ghost what's going on here falcon in winter
soldier is taking the darkest timeline approach
to that idea like what's the worst possible thing
that could happen when all these people start
coming back so part of the idea of the finale
is that there'll be some better resolution to
that like it will force the council to find some
better resolution than just deporting all these
people number eight per the trailer footage john
walker probably tries to get rid of them exactly
the way you think he does by basically killing
all the super soldiers like carly with his rinky
dink homemade captain america shield john walker
made that shield in a cave with a box of scraps
but number seven here's the thing though as pretty
much everyone has guessed after seeing that post
credit scene of him hammering the shield that very
dark twist on the iron man scene of him building
the iron man mark one armor in the cave that new
homemade shield that new cosplay looking shield
won't actually do him any good yes it is made of
regular steel his welding skills leave a little to
be desired so yes he could hurt people using the
shield however because it's not vibranium it's way
easier for the super soldier flag smashers like
carly to deal with in battle like you see her here
kicking it as if it's a soccer ball like no big
deal if it were vibranium and because john walker
is a super soldier with super strength if he threw
it at her with intent to kill the vibranium shield
it would probably break her foot in her leg also
too because falcon has the new vibranium wing suit
he could use his wings to slice that shield
up pretty easily so number six another really
big prediction the narrative of the show has
purposefully set up john walker to fail at his
task of destroying everyone in the finale and fail
miserably mostly because the major turn of the
finale one of the major twists is falcon really
becoming the new captain america in saving the day
so to speak in a very public way with the whole
world watching remember the title of episode 4
is the whole world is watching and it was
basically a metaphor for john walker being caught
by the whole world on those camera phones killing
the flag smasher so what better way for falcon to
be acknowledged as the new captain america than
to prevent a whole bunch of senseless killing by
keeping things from escalating in the finale which
is exactly what john walker is so infamous for now
yes he does solve problems but he does them in
the worst possible way imaginable the whole reason
he was stripped of the captain america title
from the government was because he got caught
killing the flag smashers in public like yes
we want you to get rid of them but do it in a
way that won't cause an international incident so
the newer captain america wingsuit looking version
of falcon saving the day will probably wind up
being the opposite of that episode 4 ending scene
saving the day in the most public way possible
but in a way that inspires a lot of hope in people
forcing the government to acknowledge him as
the new captain america in tangentially after
that falcon being able to use some of his pull his
public persona to get justice for isaiah bradley
in forcing the government to add him to the
captain america exhibit at the smithsonian
and maybe his former squad mates as well like they
had a whole section about the weapons plus program
in the people that were killed as part of
the super soldier test back in the 1950s
number five prediction behind the scenes the
government official here who took the shield
back from falcon in episode 1 and then made
john walker captain america then promptly took
the title away from him and now who's being super
shady trying to rush the vote of the grc will also
get his comeuppance like he's meant to come off as
a super shady dude obviously he doesn't care about
any of the refugees in his himself causing a lot
of problems even though it seems like he's on the
side of law and order like he's meant to be the
worst possible politician you could imagine but
in a less obvious mustache twirling way than say
like gary chandling's hydra character he was the
senator who tried to rake iron man over the coals
in iron man 2 but then later in captain america
winter soldier it was revealed that he had been
a member of hydra the entire time one of the evil
guys and the funny thing about this character is
they haven't even given him a name in the credits
he just called government official normally the
way they've used him in the series you think he's
a slightly bigger character number four carly and
the flag smashers will probably accomplish most of
their goals creating a huge international incident
that will bring a lot of attention and sympathy to
the plight of the people in the camps but since
she's killed a whole bunch of innocent people
she is a full-blown criminal and because she's
also a super soldier she and any of the other flag
smasher super soldiers who wind up surviving the
finale will probably get thrown in the raft prison
along with baron zemo i know a lot of people are
wondering if they kill any of these characters off
during the finale they'll probably kill at least a
couple of the flag smasher characters it would be
weird if it was a completely bloodless finale but
at least right now just based on the way they're
trying to spin this character they want her to be
this very optimistic but misguided anti-hero so
i think because she has super powers and she's a
pretty decent actress it would be weird of marvel
to just throw the character away when they could
always bring her back in a future project number
three not really expecting to see a ton of julie
louie dreyfus's val character in the finale but i
do think they'll at least have a couple scenes one
to address her contacting john walker and two her
possibly being the one to help set up thunderbolts
spin-off and potentially bigger things in a
post-credits scene i do think there'll be at
least two post-credits scenes technically like a
mid-credit scene and then an actual post-credits
scene just like we saw during the Wandavision
finale but it does seem like the way they're
positioning her character she's a really big deal
with a lot of power operating behind the scenes
in a shady way so she possibly come back in future
mcu projects in some form or another number two
as for thunderbolts predictions that's what most
of the talk has been about when they were first
talking about the falcon winter soldier series
setting up the idea of the thunderbolts in the mcu
through baron zemo's character as sort of like a
future anti-hero spin-off disney plus series
like the way that dc is doing an hbo suicide
squad series thunderbolts is basically marvel's
version of the suicide squad bunch of criminals
working on a team together sometimes working for
the side of law and order to get time taken off of
their sentences and if you're not a big comic book
reader the whole idea of the thunderbolts becoming
a thing in the mcu also goes hand in hand with
the idea the dark avengers might become a thing
because a lot of what's happening in the mcu right
now in the marvel disney plus series in the future
marvel movies is similar to what was happening in
this big paradigm shift in the comics between big
comic book events it's just that the events
themselves were a little bit different like
the whole idea of who is responsible for keeping
the world safe after these major events happen so
the events in the comics that sort of precipitated
this were them entering the dark rain period after
an avengers secret invasion event in the movies
obviously it's a similar situation but it's all
coming from avengers end game thanos's invasion
and the official avengers team sort of disbanding
temporarily after that happened if it wasn't clear
a lot of the producers have kind of explained
that in the mcu there's really no avengers team
that is active at the moment even though some
of the avengers are still alive in falcon still
calls himself an avenger like when he was trying
to get himself that bank loan and they made the
joke about the avengers not getting paid like we
don't really get paid it doesn't really work like
that but there is no present actual avengers team
right now as for who would be on that thunderbolts
roster obviously that's always up for grabs there
are a bunch of characters that are still alive a
bunch of super villains that are still alive in
the mcu that are probably on the raft right
now that baron zemo will be in proximity to
pretty much any big super villain character that's
too powerful to be put in a regular prison gets
thrown in the raft as of captain america civil
war that's sort of like thunderbolt ross's secret
guantanamo bay style prison where they lock you
up and throw away the key then really big one
number one prediction here's the idea that a lot
of people have been wondering about the creation
of a potential dark avengers team in the mcu as
thunderbolt ross's way of replacing the avengers
on a bigger scale than the thunderbolts if you're
not a big comic book reader the dark avengers in
the comics were created by norman osborne after he
took credit for saving the world from the scrolls
at the end of marvel's secret invasion event
so imagine the worst possible person a villain
super villain getting the credit for saving
the world during that event a bunch of heroes
actual avengers characters were either killed or
injured so badly they weren't able to continue in
the avengers right away and because norman osborne
was given control of the team most of the classic
avengers roster revolted quitting in protest like
i'm not going to work for you you're terrible that
gave norman osborne the opportunity to replace
them with a team of avengers that suited his own
personal agenda and he basically replaced the core
roster with a bunch of supervillain anti-heroes
that had similar powers to the classic roster so
for instance norman osborne replaced iron man as
the leader calling himself the iron patriot using
some of iron man's armor that he had repurposed
roadie was kind of a version of iron patriot for
a hot minute during iron man 3. they don't really
have that character anymore they could always
bring him back in some form but probably not but
obviously things are very different in the mcu we
don't have norman osborne yet even though it seems
like we might see him during future spider-man
movies but we do have thunderbolt ross who is
totally capable of becoming red hulk in the
future and even though he was a thunderbolts
character they could just escalate things and
make that a much bigger marvel movie twist and
do a dark avengers spin on it but because it's
such a big idea dark avengers and you want the
biggest possible characters to put on that team
they would wait to do that until you have more of
the fox x-men characters the rebooted versions of
characters and rebooted fantastic four villains in
the mcu which is going to take a while my full
falcon winter soldier episode 6 finale video
will post on friday but i will also do separate
videos for all the different post credit scenes
depending on what those are and what they wind
up teasing everyone post all your predictions for
the finale in the comments below just let me know
what you want to see in those post credits scenes
while you wait for everything click here for my
brand new marvel shang chi trailer finally got
some footage and click here for my falcon and
winter soldier episode 6 finale trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!